نبدا ساعتنا الثانيه بموضوع السعاده
والمال لكن بين الازواج فمن المعروف ان
المال يتصدر المرتبه الاولى للخلافات
الزوجيه لكن دراسه جديده بجامعه انديانا
الامريكيه وجدت الحل سلام والحل مشاهدينا
في هذه الدراسه والى كمان يعادل اظهر ان
الازواج الذين يتشاركون الموارد الماليه
يعني حساباتهم البنكيه مثلا يتمتعون
بعلاقات افضل الازواج الذين لديهم حسابات
مصرفيه مشتركه وفق الدراسه لا يتمتعون فقط
بعلاقات افضل لكنهم يتشاجرون بشكل اقل على
المال يشعرون بتحسن بشان كيفيه التعامل مع
الشؤون الماليه للاسره
واقل علماء ان دمج الاموال يعني ان
الازواج اكثر انسجاما في اهدافهم الماليه
وانهم اكثر شفافيه مع بعضهم البعض كما انه
يؤدي ايضا الى فهم مشترك للزواج
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا هي دراسه غربيه يعني رح يكون مثير
للاهتمام انه نعرف اذا كانت بالفعل ممكن
تنطبق علينا عنا في العالم العربي كونه
انه في عنا يعني وضوح اكثر في الادوار في
يعني داخل العلاقات الزوجيه خلينا نشوف
سالنا الناس وين سال الناس في السعوديه ما
رايكم بدمج حساباتكم الماليه مع شريك
لزواج اسعد ايش قالوا
احس انه اذا كان شريك الحياه يستاهل انه
ادمج معه حياتي ماليه وكل شيء طبيعي ندمج
معه بالعكس عشان نكبر سوا انا وهو لكن اذا
كان يعني مو قد المسؤوليه مو قد كده لا
معلش انا همسك الحسابات ماليه كلها
بالنسبه لدمج يعني الامور الماليه بيني
وبين الزوجه يعني بمستقبل ان شاء الله انا
اعتبر انو ممتاز وكويس لانه يعني
لحياه اسعد واللي زواج افضل وعشان يكون في
شفافيه ويكون في وضوح طبعا انا ضد هذا
الشيء في الوقت الحالي هذا يعني يمكن قبل
20 سنه انا بقول ممكن هذا الشيء بيصير لكن
في الوقت اللي الحين لا
هي فكره كويسه ولكن في بعد مده طويله من
الجواز بتبقى افضل مش من البدايه على طول
والله خطوه جريئه في ناس تسويها بس احسها
مجازفه بالنسبه لي انها مجازفه حسابات
الماليه
لها ظروف معينه اولا قد يمكن انك انت صاحب
شركات او صاحب اموال او صاحب علاقات دوليه
او علاقات داخليه مع شركات مع مؤسسات مع
هذا فانت ما تستطيع تشركها مباشره لا ما
في مشكله عادي اذا كان هم اثنين متفقين ما
فيها
مشكله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو مدربه الحياه فاتن
عياش الاخصائيه في التنميه البشريه اهلا
بك صدفه معنا في صباح العربيه اهلا طيب
اذا دراسه تتحدث عن انه يعني المشاركه
الماليه ما بين الازواج هي احد اسرار نجاح
العلاقه الزوجيه هاي دراسه غربيه هل تنطبق
عنا هنا في العالم العربي كون انه يعني
الادوار النمطيه للزوج والزوجه وما له وما
عليه وبالتالي هي كمان اكثر وضوحا نوعا ما
لسانا شوي تقليديين بشكل عام في مجتمعنا
هل برضو بتنطبق عنا راويه انا بقول ايه
ليش بتنطبق لانه الاشخاص هن اشخاص وين ما
كنا يعني انا من خلال خبرتي عم بشتغل مع
كل الجنسيات وكل العرب وغير العرب وبشوف
انه اذا انا قادره اوثق بزوجي بموضوع
الفلوس معناتها انا نكستب انه دار اوثق
فيه انو نجيب اولاد لانه بموضوع الزواج
ليش الناس تتزوج باخر تنهار لحتى ياسسوا
عائله فاذا انا مش قادره اقوسها بزوجي
بموضوع الفلوس فكيف عم بوثق انه انا اكيد
لانه يعني هي علاقه بين اثنين ليش ما
تثقين بهذا الزوج الا من خلال تجربته
بالفلوس
طيب اسالك بالمقابل ليش انت ما فيك توثق
بالست بموضوع الفلوس
ما راح يتزوجها
يعني الدراسه تقول
الحسابات المشتركه معناتها مشاكل اقل هل
هذا اكيد
وضوح
على الاكونت تبع
ول انا وزوجي يعني هذا رح تطبقين المثل
المصرياتك الي ومصرياتي الي
طب مشلول هيك مين اهم الاولاد ولا الفلوس
انا بالنسبه لالي اهم شيء الولاد
هل نتحدث احنا هون عن ضروره انه يكون في
حسابات مشتركه ولا هي الفكره تتعلق
بالنظره العقليه لموضوع حياتنا الماليه
المشتركه يعني اذا انا بغض النظر حتى لو
حسابي انا خاص في انا وحساب زوجي خاص فيه
هو ولكن احنا الاثنين بننظر لمالي وماله
على انه ما لنا صح هل هل هذا هو اساس
الموضوع ولا ترجمته لحساب مشترك حط هذا
هون هل لازم لحتى تكونوا الزوجين سعيدين
يكون حسابهم مشترك لا اكيد لا بس انه اذا
كان الحساب مشترك الدراسه عم بتقول انه
تبينت انه بيصيروا سعداء اكثر انا بالنسبه
لي لانه باي علاقه حتى لو مش زواجنا نحن
ما فينا نبني علاقه من دون ثقه اكيد هي
اساس كل علاقه البشر ونحن مبرمجين
كهيومن بينز انه يكون في عنا ويكون في عنا
روابط او او
فاذا انا بموضوع السقى ما عندي هذا
الثقه اكيد راح تاثر على ساعات
الموضوع السعاده مرتبط
وامشي معاي خطوبه لا ربما انا واحد من
الناس اقول بانه الرجل يجب ان لا يتزوج
امراه اذا كان يخرجها من بيت اهلها
ويعيشها بمستوى اقل اما افضل واما
لكن اليوم حتى اقنع هذا الزوج وهذه الزوجه
انه يعني تشاركوا حساباتكم هو يقول مثلا
انه لا والله انا اتكفل بايجار البيت
اتكفل بالطعام والمسكن والى اخره وانت
تتكفلين بهذه الامور معرفه هاي الواجبات
تنهي مساله ولا لازم هذا الحساب المشترك
وهذا الوضوح المالي
حسيت انك انت
مش عادي حتى
انا مس
جل لها الشخص اللي كثير متمسك انه هو
يعطيها بس مثلا
مخبيه خصوصيه ليش ليش
خصوصيه بمرتك على انه خصوصيه صح
في التنميه البشريه يعطيك العافيه شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات